also breaking tonight the third story in
a row there are new developments in the
hunter biden email story
your senior political correspondent mike
emanuel in washington good evening mike
brett good evening one senior federal
official tells fox news
the fbi and doj concur with dni john
ratcliffe's assessment
that hunter biden's laptop and emails
were not part of a russian
disinformation campaign
and the senior federal official says the
fbi is in possession
of the hunter biden laptop in question
that breaking moments ago
also late today a new photo has emerged
in the new york post
showing former vice president joe biden
son hunter and purported
kazakh officials it is undated we're
checking with our sources to get as much
information as we can about it
and the proper context as we are with
all the new revelations
in this hunter biden story big
tech about to be under the spotlight
negotiations continue with senate
judiciary
which is threatening subpoenas for the
ceos of facebook and twitter on thursday
we should have no more foot dragging we
should have proactive
action here to address the concentration
to address the power to address the
censorship
some republicans charging censorship
even election
interference as the social media
platforms blocked
distribution of the initial hunter biden
email story
you look at all the corruption in this
family it's tremendous corruption
nobody's ever seen i mean that
laptop nobody has ever seen anything
like that he's gone into hiding
president trump accusing joe biden of
staying away from reporters ahead of
thursday night's debate to avoid
answering questions
about his son hunter's purported laptop
and emails
the president also jumped on this may
2017 email
with chinese energy executives verified
by a source on the email chain
which discusses payment for six people
it includes a reference to ten percent
of the equity in the deal being held by
h assumed to be hunter for the big guy
which sources say
is joe biden the vice president got a
kickback
and everybody knows it and they've known
it for a long time fox news has obtained
images including what appears to be a
receipt from the wilmington delaware
computer repair shop
signed by hunter biden it also listed an
email and cell phone number for him
and documentation from the fbi's
interaction with shop owner john paul
mack
isaac it shows the bureau took
possession of an alleged hunter biden
laptop
and external hard drive last december
senate homeland security chairman ron
johnson wants answers about the fbi's
actions
since then the fbi owes us a defensive
briefing if
if this shop owner is is fraudulently
peddling information the to the congress
that's a crime the fbi ought to brief us
on that as well investigative journalist
glenn greenwald notes the biden campaign
silence on the authenticity of what's
been reported
no one in the biden camp not hunter
biden not joan biden not anyone with the
biden campaign is even insinuated let
alone stated
that the emails are anything other than
authentic the fbi has made
every effort to stay out of the 2020
election after it was front and center
in 2016 with hillary clinton's emails
and her private server
but tonight some breaking news we are
told by a senior federal official that
the fbi is in possession of a laptop
and that the fbi and doj concur with the
director of national intelligence
that this is not part of a russian
disinformation campaign brett
well that's significant mike will stay
on that more on this with the panel